[Musik]
hier guck mal ich habe einen fotoauftrag
von einer frauenzeitschrift bekommen da
sieht er noch eine männerzeitschrift aus
findest du das zu ich finds gut aber
warum geht es also und das thema sind
frauen und männerberufe
deshalb habe ich diese frau in der
typischen berufsbekleidung eines
bauarbeiters dargestellt ok also du
möchtest frauen in typischen
männerberufen fotografieren oder auch
männer in typischen frauenberufen beides
es geht um gleichberechtigung und
gehaltsunterschiede zwischen männern und
frauen
und ich überlege die ganze zeit welche
berufe typische männerberufe sind naja
die handwerker berufe oder lackierer
maurer klempner beruf kraftfahrer
lkw-fahrer habe ich auch schon auf
meiner liste
und bei den typischen frauenberufen habe
ich friseurin erzieherinnen sekretärin
und verkäuferin
es gibt aber auch viele friseure ich
finde nicht dass es ein typischer
frauenberuf ist apropos beruf wie lange
willst du denn eigentlich noch
weitermachen
wegen des babys keine ahnung
so lange es geht ich glaube das problem
wird er die zeit nach der geburt
also das heißt du du willst das baby auf
jeden fall behalten
mitbewohner nummer fünf
ist es schön